okay this is what we call crazy fan
theory but who knows it might be
real if you've watched my video that I
just released not too long ago about the
Walking Dead Season six finale I
mentioned in there that I don't like
what they're doing with Carol's
character they turned her from badass to
this girl who sobs and hyperventilates
and I thought it was stupid as I was
editing that video something struck me
almost like lightning and it's raised a
total theory I have no proof of it but
there is evidence that stacks up to make
you go maybe and if a blogger thought of
this they put it on a blog Facebook
Facebook I'm a YouTube guy so it's going
on YouTube so here we go oh and spoiler
alert if you haven't seen the finale of
season six of The Walking Dead watch
that first then watch this alright
you've been warned okay so in the
beginning of the finale of The Walking
Dead
those guys block the road and they tell
that dude they're kicking his ass so
like we're gonna make an example out of
you for someone and they're just there
but Rick and his crew aren't there yet
so they obviously know Rick and his crew
are coming how and I thought to myself
did they have a spy like did what have
Rick's people was there a spy in there
somewhere
I'm not saying Carol's a spy I'm saying
what if Carol did some for negan
that she didn't want to do but negan
made her do here's what happened Carol
left for reasons unknown to us and then
about a day later Maggie gets sick and
is having pregnancy problems if it was a
fact that Maggie was poisoned the prime
suspect for it would be the one who fled
town a day earlier I'm not saying she
wanted to do this I'm saying
Carol's mannerisms her character started
to change about the time that they were
captured Carol and Maggie were captured
now I don't know what happened in
between when they got bagged and when
they were in the room together
what if they didn't arrive in the room
at the same time what if Carol had a
meeting with negan and what if negan was
like okay your people are killing my
people I'm kind of pissed about that so
I need you to do something I need you to
poison the pregnant chick but if that's
why Carol was hyperventilating in the
room with Maggie what if she was looking
at her friend like I need to kill this
girl no and for those of you who'd be
like she would never do that to Maggie
in a million years she has done that to
people in her little Family Circle she
did it in the
jail remember when there was that
outbreak and then two people who had the
virus were murdered it was kind of this
murder mystery ruler who did it we find
out it was Carol so she has done it
before granted she can't have been as
attached to them as she's been to Maggie
because it's been is now a few years
later and you're gonna get more attached
to a person so it's gonna affect you
more affect you so much more that you're
going to just leave town and want to die
somewhere too and Morgan came across
Carolyn the finale Carol was kind of
curled up she clearly wants to die but I
was looking at her I was thinking back
actually retrospectively at the time I
just I was like what are they doing to
Carol but retrospectively looking back
she does seem like someone who was
wracked with guilt like she did
something that she feels is wrong she
did something bad and I could see
someone who poisoned one of their
friends fleeing town because they're
just ashamed they can't look these
people in the eye anymore which does
coincide with when she hyperventilation
starts freaking out negan said he's
really pissed at Rick's people are
killing his people and they have to be
punished because of it and then when
Carol was driving and those guys cut her
off and they're in their car and she
starts crying she's like don't do this
it doesn't need to be this way but she
does kill them because it was them or
her but I noticed that she really freaks
out when she's going to kill negan's
people like she knows it's going to lead
to worse and maybe that's why she
didn't want to kill those guys and
that's why she was like please don't
because she's like if I kill these
people
negan is gonna kill my people I
attributed to it's like Lando Calrissian
Lando Calrissian was a good dude and Han
Solo was his best friend but he betrayed
his best friend and he gets a bad rap
for that but we do not know what Darth
Vader threatened him with what if Darth
Vader was like you're gonna hand over
your one friend or I'm gonna take every
child and put him foot first in the
incinerator then every woman and I'm
gonna put her foot first in the
incinerator and then every guy I'm going
to slowly crush his from feet to head
and then throw him over the balcony and
he's going to die on the way like we
don't know what he was threatened with
what if Lando just had no choice but to
betray his friend
what if Lando had no choice but to
betray her friend now for the
foreshadowing I was watching a few of
the episodes leading up to the Walking
Dead finale and I remember Morgan and
Rick are out there looking for Carol and
they're talking and they bring up the
jail scenario where Carol killed
somebody and he was like but you exiled
her and Rick
like banker now she killed a couple
people who saved all our lives and
Morgan was like well that was in and
this is now and they start
philosophically debating it I can't help
but think that that is foreshadowing for
what's to come
Ric said he would thank her now but
would he really thank her if it was
Maggie kill one person save everybody
what if negan was like you killed that
one person I won't kill everybody but if
you don't kill that person hey that's my
army everyone's gonna die everyone you
love and some more foreshadowing we've
seen this scenario before where negan
was like you kill one person and then
you save another person when Jesus took
him to that town to talk about treading
and these guys came back from Meghan's
place and he's like yeah they killed a
bunch of us I still have someone they
want me to give you a message I'm really
sorry and he stabs the guy just like I
need to do it I need to do it you need
to kill this one guy for negan in order
to save his friend I feel like that
scenario was just hard for shadowing for
what Carol's going through guys in the
end I have no proof of any of this it
just kind of struck me and I was like oh
my god what if Carol's sudden change of
character isn't actually sloppy what if
it's just she's wracked with guilt and
wants to die because she poisoned her
pregnant friend to save everybody in the
town that negan was going to kill and
what if actually negan was like not
gonna kill everybody yet if you do this
one thing and then the guys stopped her
on the road and she sliced them all down
and that's when negan was like Lonnie
has to pay the piper and that and she
knows that what if she just curled up at
the porch of the house when Morgan finds
her because she's like someone's gonna
die because I killed those guys because
no matter what this girl wants to die
she called that dude back who found her
to kill her she for some reason she
wants to die and it just looks like she
feels guilty for something and I feel
like negan made her do something that
she didn't want to do and coincidentally
Maggie got sick right after she left and
I feel like you'd take a day for the
poison to kick in maybe she poisoned her
food and then she ate it the next day
had to be clear I don't know what I want
to be true at this point is it better
that they're just writing Carole in a
way that I don't like or is it better
that Carole tried to kill somebody that
she loves I don't know what I would
prefer not and you know what I would
prefer the second one because at least
at that point it's smart writing don't
like that you
hate what we're doing with Carol but you
have no idea why point is very
fascinating but what I need from you
guys is straight-up scrutiny I need you
guys to tell me what I'm missing tell me
what I'm getting maybe there are things
that I didn't mention they actually
coincide with this that actually
validate and support this theory maybe
there are other things that completely
rip it apart
I'm curious Matt it's just a theory at
this point I'm not hanging my hat on it
but I think it's an interesting take it
actually makes me like what they're
doing with Carol so if this is true what
I said about Carol's character in my
Walking Dead finale video just just push
that aside and take this as what I feel
about it
right so Carol being guilty because
negan made her do some what do you
think about that theory whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more